I'm going to talk about something join
work with Eric play on approximating
boolean functions with two circuits so
we're going to be concerned with DNFs
which is a very simple object is the or
events i'm going to call each and a term
and i'm going to be concerned with two
complexity measures of DNFs two very
basic ones the size and width the size
of the dnf is just a number of terms in
a dnf the width of a term is a number of
literals occurring the term and the
width of a dnf is just the maximum width
of any term occurring in the dnf ok so
that's what a dnf is is a very simple
mathematical object in this talk it may
be useful to visualize a dnf as the
union of sub cubes and in particular
size s with W dnf is the union of S sub
cubes of dimension Eddie's n minus W and
the correspondence should be clear every
term corresponds to a sub Hume the one
thing I just want to emphasize is that a
term of small width corresponds to a
cube of large dimension and in this talk
I'm gonna switch back and forth between
viewing a dnf s you know a circuit and
the DMF esta unión off sub cubes ok so
that's what a dnf is ok so the starting
point of this research is a very simple
exercise that's often used to introduce
complexity theory it's a very simple
exercise it says that any dnf that
computes parody the parody function has
set up sighs at least 2 to the N minus 1
and with at least n ok it's not hard to
prove you just notice that everyone
input as we have its own sub cube and
that's the proof and this is a classic
example of a lower bound and like you
know a concrete model of computation
equally easy is the fact that in fact
every boolean function can be computed
by the NF of size and most 2 to the N
minus 1 and trivially with an most n so
commenting combining these two facts we
see that parodies in fact the hardest
function okay so nothing nothing too
difficult going on here in general we
have a very good understanding of the
dnf complexity of functions just because
they are not very complicated objects by
this talk I'm going to be interested in
a slight twist where the DLF doesn't
have to compute a function exactly but
it just required to be correct on a
point 99 fraction of inputs and what I
hope to convince you is there with this
slight twist you know these like simple
exercises become interesting open
problems so let me get the key
definition hopefully the only definition
of the talk of the way I'm going to say
the boolean function f
an epsilon approximator for boolean
function G if they differ on an epsilon
fraction of inputs okay so that's really
the only definition we need okay let me
start with three questions that we
didn't quite know the answer to either
side of this research the first question
is it's approximating parody
asymptotically easier than computing it
exactly we saw that computing parody you
require roughly to the n terms to the N
minus 1 terms can you do can you zero
point one approximate parody with sighs
you know to the n over log in or to the
realm for poly n so that's the first
question that's the first question is
slightly specific parody the second
question is a more global question we
saw that parody is the hottest function
to compute exactly is it also the
hottest function to approximate so
that's n in order to answer the second
question we also have to answer the
questions like the third one which is
universal bounds on approximating every
boolean function so here we are
interested in statements of the sword
every boolean function can be 0.1
approximated by a dnf of size blah ok so
these are the three questions that we
couldn't quite answer and in this
research we make some progress on all
three of them oh so the theme of this
this paper is on trade-offs between
accuracy and efficiency in circuit
complexity and what I hope to convince
you is that you know very basic and
seemingly simple problems I open even
for you know very simple circuits like
DNFs so let me give you some of let me
go into more details about the three
questions okay so we have this theorem
of loop on/off which I stayed on my
first slide which is any dnf computing
the parody function has have size at
least 2 to the N minus 1 and with a BSN
the first question you can ask is that
0.1 approximating parity require size
Omega of 2 to the N or can you zero
point 1 and proximate parody with size
little off to 10 okay so that's a
qualitative question you can all say you
get more quantitative so we can live in
two different worlds one where
approximation is not much easier it
could be the case in 0.1 approximating
parody require size Omega of 210 meaning
you get not much more than a constant
factor savings or approximation could
make things a lot easier you could 0.1
approximate parody with size to the
landover exponential in turn right we
didn't know which world we live in so
that size and we can ask the same
question about with right as 0.1
approximating parody required the end
with n minus Big O of 1 meaning you get
nothing more than just a constant factor
additive savings oh can we 0.1
approximate parody with with n minus
little omega of one alright so that's a
qualitative question again and you can
get quantitative and as far as I know
before we started this research again
there was this two worlds where our
proximity was not much easier and 0.1
approximating parody requires with n
minus big of one approximation made
things a lot easier you could
approximate parody with size and width
width n minus Omega of n okay okay so
before I state our results let me answer
a question that we may be on some of
your minds which is what does the
switching Lamar say so I'm going to
touch briefly on the work on correlation
bounds between parity and AC 0 and how
our work relates to it and how it
differs from it so this a long and
fruitful line of research is starting an
80s it's still active today and the main
message of this research is that a small
AC 0 Circuit agrees with parody on a
half plus tiny fraction of inputs so
here tiny is a function of the size of
your circuit the depth of your circuit
that may be n ok and just last year
Johann a resolve Johann implies that the
correlation of any size sdmf with
parodies at most 2 to the minus Omega
end of log s so this is what I call tiny
on the line above so what does this say
about the size of DNFs that agree with
parody on 99% of inputs which is the
question that we are interested in for
this work it does say something and thus
is something pretty strong if there's
any dnf agrees with parity on 99% of
inputs massive size to the Omega n in
particular it cannot be you cannot hope
to get like two to the root n but I
claim that there's still some
interesting work to be done and which is
what I what we do in this work it still
leaves to open this exponential gap that
I mentioned previously whether the true
answer is omega of two to the N or
versus an upper bound of two design /
exponential in n so that's this too
still this exponential gap that remains
and this is what we close this one of
the things we close in this work okay so
let me start describing our results
office theorem is an analog of lupinus
theorem we show that every for every
episode approximating parody we show
that for every epsilon parody can be
epsilon approximated by a dnf of size 2
to the 1 minus 2 epsilon times n and
with 1 minus 2 epsilon times n so for
constant epsilon this is exponential
savings on size and linear savings on
width
and we complement these upper bounds
with almost matching lower bounds we
show that for every epsilon any dnf the
epsilon approximates parody requires
slice at least 12 to the 1-4 epsilon
times N and with at least one minus 2
epsilon times n so I'll bounce on with
match exactly and our bounds on sighs
come close to matching modulo this like
two verses for an exponent so that's our
results for parody and before I describe
our other results I just want to spend
one slide on why this result is still a
little surprising to me till today let's
focus on with if they say parody can be
epsilon approximated by DF of with 1
minus 2 epsilon times n so if you fix
epsilon to be constant this is n minus
Omega of n and recall from my second
slide that this means that parody can be
0.1 approximated or 0.01 approximated
but a union of linear dimensional sub
cubes and by being linear dimensional
each sub cube covers exponentially many
points right and since the underlying
function is parody for everyone I cover
I cover 80 as well so if you just zoom
in on one sub Q bin my approximator I'm
making area fifty percent right and yet
somehow we can align the cubes in such a
way that the overall error is one
percent which means pretty
counterintuitive and I'm going to prove
this later but just briefly the solution
is to somehow get these keeps overlap
very heavily over the 0 inputs meaning a
double count my errors a lot and yet be
essentially disjoint over the one inputs
so I cover lots of one inputs okay so
that's parody so now we move on to more
global questions about universal bounds
we saw that parodies hardest function
compute exactly is it true it's also the
hardest function compute how dysfunction
approximate by DNFs so our next result
says no any dnf that 0.1 approximates a
random function require has size at
least 2 to the N over N and we call our
bound on size for parody we show that
parody can be epsilon approximated by
dnf of size at most 2 to the 1 minus 2
epsilon times n so if you plug in
epsilon constant here you get
exponential savings so among other
things this shows that parody despite
being the hardest function to compute
exactly it is in fact exponentially
easier to approximate and almost every
other function
okay so in light of this lower bound we
can ask you know what about the bounds
in particular the question that really
like what is their function they require
size Omega of 2 to the 1 2 to the N the
0.1 approximate or is it possible to
every single boolean function we can get
some sort of savings and we should I in
fact every single boolean function we
can get some sort of savings we show
that every boolean function can be 0.1
approximated by the NF of size and most
2 to the n over log in okay so that's
sighs let me move on to width okay so a
few slides ago we saw that parody can be
0.1 approximated by the union of linear
dimensional sub cubes well
optimistically we can ask can we do this
for every single boolean function and in
fact yes we show that every boolean
function can be 0.1 approximated by the
by dnf up with a moes n minus Omega of n
the union of linear dimensional sub
cubes which is pretty interesting and
one reason why is interesting is it
gives the interesting contrast between
approximate and exact computation a very
simple counting argument or
probabilistic argument shows that in a
random function everyone monochromatic
sub-q meaning is sub cube with all one's
has dimension at most log in so one way
to look at our result is that we show
that all every single one of these cubes
can be made exponentially larger at a
cost of some small error six small
constant error 0.1 okay so that's our
results let's prove some stuff so I'm
going to go sort of in a reverse order
in which I presented the results I'm
going to start with our Universal bounce
fur is starting with size and then going
to width and then closing off without
the NF approximated for parody and I'll
end up with some open problems okay so
first theorem every boolean function can
be 0.1 approximated by dnf of size at
most 2 to the n over log n so think of
health and mine a random function for
example how are we going to do this
what's our goal well goal is to put down
a small family of sub cubes and by small
I mean to turn n over log in that covers
almost all the one inputs my missus
almost all the 0 inputs and it seems
pretty tough here's the first attempt
this is probably the most technical
proof and
so I'm going to try to prove it three
times starting with the first attempt
it's a very naive attempt is probably
it's not going to work but as you'll see
it gets us very close and it's a very
simple idea the first thing I'm going to
do when I get this function is I'm going
to randomly flip a tiny fraction of
zeroes to once okay and then the next
step I'm just going to put on every
large one monochromatic sub-q okay let's
see how this does there are three things
we care about the area on the zero
inputs there on one inputs and a dnf
sighs okay I claim that we are happy we
get what we want for the error on the
zero inputs well what's our algorithm
doing we're flipping some zeros to ones
and then putting down everyone
monochromatic sub-q so you cannot cover
too many zeros just you know almost by
definition from the algorithm I claim we
are also happy on the arrow on one
inputs right fix any one input as long
as I can argue that any one input is
covered by many large sub cubes then
there's going to be a good chance that
one of them would become motor chromatic
after this corruption process and I'm
going to be cover it but I claim that
the one thing that doesn't quite make it
is the NF size and to see this it's a
very simple example you can keep in mind
imagine you're giving a constant one
function what's this algorithm going to
do well the first step is going to
randomly flip a tiny fraction of zeros
to once well it's the constant one
function nothing is going to get flipped
and a second step you're going to
include every single large one motor
chromatic sub cube you're just going to
put it down put it down put it down and
you're dnf is going to be too big so the
one the obvious fixes instead of
including every single one of them be
slightly more careful about including
which ones you want to include but this
is actually basically our algorithm so
let me show you the actual algorithm now
again the first step remains the same
I'm going to randomly flip every 0 input
to one with some tiny probability the
second step I'm going to define what we
call special sub cubes such that every X
is contained in many special sub cubes
okay in the third step I'm going to
include everyone monochromatic special
sub Q and by that I mean any special sub
cube that becomes all ones after the
corruption process in my approximated
with some small probability I claim that
this fixes the problem I had on my
previous slide so for the same reason
since i'm flipping zeros the ones and
putting down
monochrome XR pubes I'm going to cover a
tiny fraction of zeros so my error on
zero inputs is going to be good since
everyone input is cut that it's included
in many special sub cubes there's going
to be a good chance that one of them is
going to become monochromatic after the
corruption process and we can argue that
everyone input is likely to be covered
and lastly since everyone monochromatic
special sub cube is only included with a
small probability well your dnf is not
going to be too big okay so let me prove
it the third time with actual proof okay
so the first step again is to flip every
0 input to one independently with
probability and most epsilon over to so
just by a simple Chernoff bound I most
with probability with extremely high
probability and most epsilon of fraction
of 0 inputs is flipped and I want to
make gonna do next what I'm going to do
next is to put down one model chromatic
sub cubes so conditioned on this event
my arrow on the 0 inputs is going to be
small so that makes me happy so there
are two more things that we have to do
it remains to consider air on one inputs
and the dnf size so I'm going to prove
in the next slide that with probability
at least three-quarters around one input
sets and most epsilon and with
probability at least three-quarters my
dnf size is going to be at most to the n
over log in and then just by a Union
bound I'm going to get then there is
some positive probability that all three
things happen and I got again all three
properties I want ok so it remains for
me to justify these two things in green
so let DB log log n don't worry too much
about it is something that you choose
carefully when the proof is complete and
we partition n into n over 3 blocks of
size D and what's the special sub-q a
special sub cube is one where all the
stars are the free variables for exactly
in one of these blocks okay and the
observation here is every input X is
contained in exactly n of these special
sub cubes so that's what a special sub
cube is in a second stuff my algorithm
is I'm going to include everyone
monochromatic special subhuman my
approximator with probability exactly
epsilon to the two to the D oh why am I
good for my air on one inputs well for
any one input X I'm included in n over d
special sub cubes each of which is
included in my approximator with
probability exactly epsilon to the 23 d
so the probability that you're not
covered is exactly 1 minus this
inclusion probability raised to the
number of special sub-q [ __ ] is nov de
and by carefully choosing d you get this
to be at those epsilon over 4 okay and
how about size well it's just a number
of special sub-q multiplied by the
probability that any subtype is included
so just by working on paper you can
convince yourself that this is the
number of special sub-q and multiplying
it by epsilon to the 230 again by our
magical choice of the e this comes out
to to the band over log n so by Mark off
of argument for both we get what we want
so this proves our first result which is
again the every boolean function can be
0.1 approximated by dnf size and most to
the den over log in okay Universal bound
on dnf with so again I'm going to try to
convince you that every boolean function
can be 0.1 approximated by a dnf of with
a most n minus Omega of n so this is the
union of linear dimensional sub cubes
I'm going to fix d to be 0.001 n and on
my final approximator is gonna have with
n minus D which is n minus DN n the
first step is to cover in 99.999% of the
hemming cube with roughly 10 times to
the end of the volume d having balls
over USD here volume d is a volume of
hemming ball of radius T and the way to
think about this is that is essentially
a partition in fact for the rest of this
proof is probably more convenient to
just think of this as magically the
numbers work out so that we can exactly
partition the hemming cube into the
union of hemming balls and why do I say
that this is essentially a partition
well with the partition I'll cover one
hundred percent instead of 99.999% and
with the partition I'll use two to the N
over volume d having balls instead of
ten times there but it's essentially a
partition and for the proof not being
exactly a partition doesn't really hurt
us too much so we have divided and then
now we conquer so we are going to Zone
in on one hemming ball I'm going to
construct a small with dnf and by small
I mean n minus D which
n minus VTN and DNA for each ball said
if satisfying that following property
I'm going to be in ninety-nine point
nine percent correct within this ball
and zero outside it and what's my final
approximator my final approximated is
just gonna be the or of all these sub
approximator and why is my final
approximator a small with dnf well my
approximated for every ball is going to
be a small with the NF and the or of
small with DNFs remain a small with tnf
okay so it remains to justify this last
part about constructing a small with vnf
for these boolean functions restricted
to having balls and it's not so hard so
it's you're given this hemming ball it
there's some boolean function inside it
and then it's all zeros outside the key
observation here is that ninety-nine
point nine nine percent of the points
lie on surface of the ball so it
suffices to get it exactly correct on
the surface and I don't really care what
happens inside the ball and yet but but
the key properties I have to be my
approximate it has to be all zeros also
the ball well i'm just going to use one
term for everyone input on the surface
and do this for every single point on
the surface and i'm going to be hundred
percent correct on the surface and
because of the geometry of the hypercube
most points lie on the surface so this
is my approximator for the hemming balls
and recall the way i'm going to combine
them is just going to take the or of all
these small with DNFs which is going to
be a small with dnf okay so that
concludes the proof of our second
theorem which is the every boolean
function can be 0.1 approximated by dnf
with a most n minus leading then the
union of linear dimensional sub cubes
okay so for the last part of the talk
I'm going to quick quickly outline our
dnf approximator for parody so recall
that our theorem is that parody can be
epsilon approximated for every epsilon
parody can be epsilon approximated by DN
emphasize that most 2 to the 1 minutes
to epsilon times n and with at most 1
minus 2 epsilon times n I'm going to
prove this to you for epsilon being one
quarter and hopefully you'll be
convinced that we can generalize this
for a small epsilon so okay we want to
compute the parity function
given a string X we would like to find
out the parody of the bits and X so
there may be a natural thing to do is to
divide X into two blocks y and z and
make the obvious observation first of
all that parity of x is a parody of Y X
sort with a parody of Z so that's parody
one might what's my approximate are
going to be well I'm going to
approximate this function with f of X
being parody of why not x sort but
ordered with the parity of Z and let's
see how this does first of all I claim
that a pair of excess indeed one then f
of X will be one well if their own
number of ones in my string then any
partition it cannot be split even even
because if you split split even even the
total is gonna be even so in this case
actually my approximate is going to be
exactly correct so what if the parity of
x is 0 well then half the time is split
split even even and half the time is
split on in which case my approximator
is going to correct half the time so
just by this very simple observation we
see that f of X is a three products
approximated for parity so what's the
dnf size for f of X well parody of Y and
parity of Z they are functions over n
over two variables so they have trivial
DNFs exhibit computing exactly off sides
to the n over 2 minus 1 and with n over
2 and your or in these two together so
the size x to the width stays the same
so we see that we can one-quarter
approximated parody with size at most 2
to the n over 2 and with MOS and over 2
and four small epsilon you use more
blocks instead of just two blocks and
you can get it for all epsilon greater
than smaller than one quarter okay so
let's stand on my talk haha let me
conclude with a few open problems okay
so one thing we showed here is a
universal at the bone that every boolean
function can be 0.1 approximated by a
dnf of sites opposed to the band over
log in and we show a lower bound of the
design / n against a random function ok
so what in my mind is sort of I would
say this is a very fundamental question
is the closest gap and find out how
exactly what exactly the right bout is
between 2-10 and over n versus to the n
over log in and
in fact the question I like even more is
that is to find an explicit heart
function showing giving a bone of
Ellie's to the end of a polygon we know
that this is not parody and we know that
a random function is going to be hard
but i'm not sure what function is going
to be even showing me a function that is
strictly how did a parody i'll be very
happy to see right now I do not have a
candidate for a function that's strictly
hard and parity now I'll really like to
come up with a function which I can
prove explicit heart function which I
can prove that any 0.1 approximator it
has to have sighs at least to deny
Napoleon I'm guaranteed that almost
every function satisfies this I like to
find one explicit one thanks questions
solutions to the open problems beyond
the the lower bound for random functions
is by accounting argument yeah yeah
counting combined with you know the fact
that your approximate er yeah it's an
information-theoretic lower bound
Italian babies which says that the Amana
thorn function which is in ac0 the need
not be in monotone sec oh yeah but they
I don't know if it's known that the
monitor function in a CCO cannot even be
approximated in monotone Ecco and yeah
also the don't you can also talk about
you don't need to speak to put in owe me
anything yeah exactly yeah so so we may
be this question is relevant yeah yeah
with Eric and with you on we're actually
looking at a problem that's quite
closely related which is the given a
monotone function if I want to compute
it with a small size dnf it's clear that
the dnf is going to be monotone as well
it's just a union of all midterms and
what we're interested is if you just
want to 0.1 approximate a monotone
function is that function also going to
be monotone so that's sort of related to
this aight aight result on AC 0 and the
answer that is actually needs to be
surprisingly know that sometimes a non
monotone function can help you
approximate a monotone function
aim and we meet again for open problems
at 340 after one so on